my guest this week is his Holiness the
Dalai Lama as a spiritual leader of the
Tibetan people he's internationally
known as the most famous Buddhist in the
world but he describes himself simply as
a monk born in 1935 he began monastic
education at the age of six in 1959 he
was forced into Exile in India after the
suppression of the Tibetans by Chinese
troops
a lifelong advocate for peace he's been
awarded the Nobel Peace Prize for his
efforts as he reaches the end of his
time as Dalai Lama does he have any
regrets
[Music]
during this interview we're going to
talk about compassion the state of
humanity and his holiness's advice for
the new King Charles during our
conversation you'll notice there are
occasions where we rely on a translator
I began by asking whether the Dalai Lama
is optimistic about the fight against
climate change
now that is serious matter
According to some scientists now global
warming
is now year by year increasing
according my own experience
when I was in hassa
when I was young
and those
high mountain around Hasa during winter
a lot of snow
dead
even in my own lifetime
year by year less and less and less
so therefore global warming is something
reality and something very important
so there's beyond all control
I think nuclear weapon can destroy other
country but the nuclear weapon cannot
bring
more or say reasonable ecology
so therefore
now global warming
that is a very serious matter
according Buddhists sort of thinking
several occasions I visit ladakh
and previously
ladakh
lay that area
really very dry
dessert
now
people pay more attention
oh
planting more grow more
trees yes more grass
so
we can
make some effort ecology
that's important
when my one one my one my sorrow friend
he first time visit
ladakh he cried or such a poor country
now a lot of much greener
much much better
so
one Indian
my friend gave me one responsibility
that is whenever you visit these ladakh
and this area you should tell people
importance of green thing
I carried that responsibility
are you optimistic that we can do better
at looking after the planet yes no
I think
another
uh
few centuries yes we can take
then global warming
become very very serious
then eventually
world
become one small
I say
a ball of fire I mean eventually yes in
a cosmic scale yes War could become a
ball of fire so that's nature process
so till that situation come
we should be
happy
we should pay more attention about home
hardness that brings happiness
so the seven billion human being let us
remain
in the spirit of Brotherhood Sisterhood
and helping each other
never used to happen killing each other
that is our duty
while I'm talking to you there's a war
going on in Ukraine
there's a famine in Somalia we have all
sorts of examples of people doing the
exact opposite
why do you think they do not listen to
these basic principles of life these
leaders and the people implementing this
of course I have no right to criticize
them
uh
they take uh best interest for
themselves but actually short-sighted
not thinking worldwide
and still
in many part of the world still thinking
there are past experience
bully weapon
oh
now I think fortunately now China moves
one of most important population
China
India China is true true most populated
Nation now China
also you see now thinking
about
inner peace
with that thinking about uh Buddha
Dharma Buddha's message
previously Chinese
always say
reactionary
now no longer say that
more and more Chinese now showing
interest about Buddha Dharma
so some Tibetan
this University student
they say China
in vegetables
and politically controlled Tibet
but eventually we can control Chinese
Mind through Buddhism
so things are now changing things are
changing but of course the China
basically Buddhist country
under certain circumstances they is it
too much emphasis authoritarian system
now that gradually changing
do you miss Tibet
do you miss it yourself yes
of course occasionally
uh but I consider
just planted this world planet
is our home
now I am here in India
one aspect
I'm refugee
one aspect I'm longest guest of Indian
government I'm very happy
so
India free country
many people come here
and listen
or discuss with me I I want to tell to
share one information
my last day in peaking
the next day I returned to Tibet
that day
I received one message from chairman
while I participated one meeting
official meeting
headed by Liu chauci
so he received me
and then we have some discussion how to
lead
Tibetan people
and you should listen
different people sort of views
but decision you should take
told me
then at the last
foreign
Come Close closer to me
and
and express to me
your mind is a very scientific minded
wonderful
religion is opium
a little bit short
but I just remain calm
so now I'm wondering
if chairman
live longer period and heat I do not
think he still consider religion is
opium
religion really gives you Inner Strength
inner peace
so whether you believe
you see God or some other different
thing
but training of our mind
uh and
you see
they keep warm heartedness here there's
the essence of all religion
the
whether there is creator
or some some Heaven there's a different
matter
but actually we are a human being
home-heartedness here
that is very important
we can check we can train
inner peace
according my own experience
or in my daily life
at the morning
wake up I always think about inner peace
very helpful their inner peace also
brings healthy body
do you can I ask your Holiness do you
have any regrets
when I look back
over 80 years
I do not find any big mistake
some small small mistake they are okay
but all my decision
last uh few decades
all
seems become very correct
and then also you see we have a surgeons
or a way to investigate
ah
certain deities
ah we have some unique sort of practice
oh
or seeking help from certain deity
and investigate
that also
you see for me last few decades very
very helpful
so now
uh
a monk
Buddhist follower
and meantime
you see
I study
Buddhist logic
so
I always use my logical approach
but at the same time the essence of
Buddha Dharma is home heartedness
and everything interdependency
so I have no regret
uh
my several now decades
I really
utilize
my knowledge
in into practice
I'm talking to you your Holiness from
England and we have a new king we have
King Charles III we have a new king here
I know you you know him as as Prince
Charles the Prince of Wales do you have
any advice for him as he begins his
reign as one of the world's most
recognizable leaders yourself of course
Great Britain
uh since previous Dalai Lama we have
very close link
so oh
the Royal Family
wonderful
a few occasions
I have meeting
so I want to express my
prayer though
recently the queen was ready
I really feel very sad
but
while she alive
I think we should done many good things
so that is important
your life's practice has been dedicated
to compassion and the spread of it how
do you think the world is doing now
firstly
I'm a human being
our life
begin with Mother's compassion
so therefore
you say compassion
the secular Viewpoint very important
is nothing to do with religion
so religion
Private Matter
if you believe religion okay if you do
not okay
and believe this religion that religion
that's up to individual
but what we
really want is home harderness
this very century
first world war Second World War
even everyone prepared for third world
war
means killing
it just the opposite of compassion or
this our sort of brain
should utilize
for inner peace
not a weapon killing
so
we can through that way we can really
develop peaceful world yes
thank you very much for talking to me
thank you very much it was lovely to to
have your your wisdom and hear your
thoughts thank you for your time your
holiness
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again take care and
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]